hello project nation its Greg out of it
here actually editor Morgan Han from how
to's with Morgan and Ashley do yourself
a favor and go check out their YouTube
channel as soon as you can follow them
on their social media please do this
otherwise they won't keep coming on this
channel
the real rejects is quite a Filipino
subscriber base hello Sasha
I'm Filipino as well yeah usually I've
seen a couple with you
we're doing a danger anyway look watch
this Bloody Mary Bloody Mary oh my Mary
see these urban legends are stupid Kevin
wait did you say Bloody Mary three times
earlier you're like a ninja
what swab one look I'm done this is it
you can't believe now you've only been
here before we I understand it that this
is our final short it's the Soviets by
Eric Monte and once we're done dude
you're gonna be dead I'm gonna I don't
tell me you believe in men Bloody Mary
crap who believed in Bloody Mary I
believe in me and a one-man show cforce
it ham - happy Halloween kids I believe
in me too
[Music]
hi Gary from Morgan scream oh my god
no for real I don't even like to set
that all up in your eye walk in light
people clean up with this apparitions of
the Virgin Mary yet however Catholic
doctrine claims of the era of public
apparition ended with the death of the
last apostle Apostle John Matthew Luke
Bryan Oh John there is revelation
this shop really well
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what was that believing
ah what the hell going on Greg what do
you make us watch Gregory there she is
people
[Music]
I think you think it's the Virgin Mary
[Music]
[Music]
folks I'm freezing fresh pow-pow
actually focus I'm not good it scares me
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
Candace they must have a budget that
girl he was stalking you just in her
house sometimes you just gotta be done
guys
[Music]
your ass now
[Music]
I'm here firm allowing
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
okay the fly flies telling him to do
anything
I'm glad to be here for the video shows
mom now
[Music]
so creepy without
[Music]
you
[Music]
for me that was really cool huh
so you good holiday yeah yeah
holy crap anyway I've got nipple Joe
what I was all right and from there
laughs or the tech like at the end I got
the rest it's like yeah yeah David is
the clever here conserving keep walking
yeah yeah it looks like a big budget
like they put a lot of their like the
facilities really good cinematography
excellent creepy eerie editing really
solid the music man that was awesome it
was like a damn good horror short felon
technically I could see this being a
feature-length movie one of those short
film adapted to a feature lame way yeah
I mean that's a cool play on the I mean
we grew up Catholic yeah we did actually
is a full Jew when I grew up I mean I
remember they showed us they would talk
about how people what the heck was it
called the Lady of something where like
people would like hundreds of people
sometimes thousands would say like they
they all saw the Virgin Mary and it
would be like a Mexico or something one
lady aguado real bad thing cuz oh yeah
yeah well when they thought like Jesus
on a chip not what I'm already know no I
was talking about crowds of baseball
claiming they saw the Virgin Mary
basically they might have seen a demon
in this baby there's a store em burr
they showed us a short film those based
on a supposed to true story where I was
like the dancing son of like the Virgin
Mary talking to these three children and
then the people in the town didn't
believe them they said they're going to
make the Sundance and the son was
literally like dancing around so but
this is a clever twist on that I mean I
don't know if that's a common belief
that the Virgin Mary comes as a disguise
a demon comes to the skies the mother
Mary how scary with that and then the
scene one he's cooking including for
himself or his mother or his mother I
think is slowly torturing her I've
always liked bathing her he's like going
too hard and she's starting to bleed I
was a real tough
creepy and then the slide just let the
slide on the beer yeah I don't know
there's something would like anytime I
see like demonic movies there's always
something was like why why they're evil
or true hmm yeah very true yeah yeah
because I grew up Catholic
whenever I see supernatural demonic
stuff it really gets under my skin I
used to believe in this kind of stuff
really not right I still think it
possible I feel like the way you grew up
Catholic is not how I grew up Catholic
dark Catholic yeah I got a blank
Catholic I grew dark I heard about
demons and hell all that time not last
thing I thought was teachings of Jesus
somehow why are you gonna go to hell you
got to be aware demon that the Queen's
trick the devil ever told was having
people believe he wasn't real you gotta
be aware of the devil okay well he's got
you are they going to be getting those
and he was chanting and not in the movie
like enough beginning thing a little
like previews that you bloody marys well
notice though inter uh yeah yeah Bloody
Mary yeah it wasn't really the same like
these but you bring you bring a demon
yeah it's just go to the mirror got near
the bed Bloody Mary three times and
she's supposed to kill you
paladin but it wasn't it's like really
not it's not Bloody Mary like the Virgin
Mary Splinter like Mary Queen of Scots
yeah yeah it's a different kind of Mary
should we all go try that in the mirror
no man
yeah where's Mary here ah no no more
I've never done a Ouija board never you
fortune I don't think that would either
I like I have how you can't watch this
done a Ouija board you guys I'm at Toys
R Us it's come on yes I want to order
the devil's trick right there happy love
you guys I think it's only as powerful
as you believe will be I believe in the
good spirits so on and we I believe I
was there
so I don't watch the movies you guys
watch the body flow to people no one's
way with Ouija boards anymore
Yug I saw the poster I was like let's go
to GUI on do what I did
Biagio real quick I thought the dude was
a really good actor I didn't think he
over played anything he gave him the
right amount of subtlety to everything
important I was good at the end of it I
felt like it wasn't like to know people
is bracing me happy about it I mean I
like the concept of being tripping that
you're doing what you know you're like
because with Catholics believe in the
Virgin Mary so believing you're doing
right by God by committing these crimes
and I don't know kind of watching that
transformation of depression into
finding happiness through evil acts as a
fascinating part tell me why he killed
the one he was talking maybe she liked
reminding him or if he lusted after her
and that's a sin or maybe use one kill
and she was there I like how he did it
to where they didn't show him killing
her like when he just like when the we
heard somebody that's cooler like a bit
heavy yeah sometimes leaving up the
imagination at mortis is just hearing
something in the room and like that shot
yeah here lower than your chair on her
yeah those cool and yet shirt off and
I'd be implied oh I'm [ __ ] down
emotionally it though I don't want to
believe that happened
let's go that half well this was a fun
uplifting day for everyone yeah I hurry
this is just as emotionally moving as
the countless filipino commercials that
were sent my way I'm glad we could
continue the vibe
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification though click it how to do
[ __ ] with Morgan and Ashley yes is a
Motor Show way more dashing how to
finish it with
not like we don't really think they're
so you gonna lock your [ __ ] car you
press this button this is it [ __ ] oh my
god we do that no they have real how-to
videos interviews with people
celebrities we did an interview with
Greg mm-hmm the ultimate celebrity
higher than the guy who does makeup for
Oscar nominated movie way more famous
than a guitarist for a famous man it is
the true gold standard right here you
only go down from Greg yeah yeah after
me and when you get bottom Ellen Ellen
hair greatness that's why you gotta
check these to win now no [ __ ]
[ __ ] I feel yes I say it I guess